التناقضات التاريخية مادة جديدة
من الأزياء مع لهجات تؤدي إلى إعادة البناء و
انطوان والمرض تركنا و
العودة إلى المدرسة هو حقًا
هنا وقلت بصراحة هنا سأفعل
أراد قتل فتى الشمس
laliberté في الوقت المرجعي
هناك رجل لا يعيش في بلده
khassaïdes heuliez أين هو الصداع
جان لويس نادال وجاري من الضروري عندما
حتى الشجاعة لأولئك السيدات
في
في هذا المركز التجاري لجرؤ
اترك قائمة الانتظار التي عادة
يؤدي إلى مساحة كبيرة ويمكن للمرء
فهم أن الناس و
الاحتفاظ بها فيما يتعلق بذلك ، لهذا السبب
أن عرضنا ليس فقط
يشير إلى النقطة المؤقتة ولكن أيضًا
أعط إحداثيات جمعيتنا
كان الوحش القذر إلى موستار إل إن بي سينقض عليه
على القدر ولدينا صمامات لنا
يوضح أنه ليس دائمًا واضحًا
للعثور على الكلمة الصحيحة التي أخبرني عنها
تتحدث عن العنف عما هم
أشعر برغبة في طرح الأسئلة ليس الأمر كذلك
واضح أمام الأطفال لأن
الأطفال ربما يمكنهم ذلك أيضًا
الحديث مرة أخرى في مكان آخر أبي وراء ذلك
إنه أمر معقد للغاية بالنسبة للنساء
حتى عندما نحصل عليها
الهاتف من الجذع عند التلال
ملون أوبيسون الماء نهجه
كابيندا